today I'd like to talk about the bagel
problem let's suppose that we are going
to buy a dozen bagels twelve bagels and
go into the store and there are several
kinds there might be plain bagels and
poppy bagels and sesame bagels and onion
bagels and everything bagels potato
bagels there might be even blueberry
bagels and the question is how many ways
for a given number of kinds of bagels
can we purchase a bag full of twelve
bagels let's say that I want to buy a
dozen bagels and there are four kinds
plain poppy sesame and onion I might buy
three of each kind and that would make
the dust but it's possible that I really
like puppies so I might buy five poppy
and then I would buy fewer of the other
kinds there's every possible combination
for example I can just buy all Bunyan
and none of the others I can buy eleven
and one I can buy you know eight and one
and one and one one whatever works out
to be twelve so I have total freedom and
if I'm picking and choosing the order in
which I choose things does not matter
it's not like I'm going to know which
bagel am I going to choose first doesn't
matter the only thing that matters is
the total outcome at the end of the game
you have to buy twelve bagels and you're
not required to buy at least one of any
of the kinds you can really despise
ignore one of the kinds or ignore all
but one of a kind so the store will not
run out they have deep bins even if
you're buying four dozen or ten dozen
they won't keep supplying you with the
bagels you need how many different
combinations of bagels can I get in a
bag okay well I think what we should
really do is we should focus on
numerical examples and see what the
point is and then at the end we'll have
some formula so think about a dozen
bagels some people might think a baker's
dozen is 13 but let's say twelve bagels
and we might to start vary the numbers
of kinds like suppose we go into a store
that just sells traditional plain bagels
how many different ways can buy twelve
bagels the answer is just one way we
might go into a slightly more
interesting store that has two kinds of
bagels plain bagels and chocolate bagels
and then how many ways can we buy the
twelve bagels so now the answer is more
interesting we can buy 0 plain bagels
we could buy one plain bagel we could
buy two plain bagels we can go all the
way up to twelve plain bagels and then
of course the other bagels the bagels
that are chocolate just fill in so that
altogether we get well how many ways are
there to buy twelve bagels when there
are two kinds and the answer is given by
this range of possibilities and actually
there are thirteen choices if I look at
all the numbers from zero to twelve
inclusive thirteen when there are two
kinds namely it's the number of bagels
you're buying plus one that'll be the
answer now let's say there are going to
be three khans blueberry
let's have bubblegum bubblegum babe
that's going to be tough the third bagel
will be caramel and then the number of
blueberry bagels that we buy can be
anything from zero up to twelve and then
the number of bagels left for the other
two kinds will go from 12 down to zero
now we already saw that if we're buying
a dozen bagels and there are two kinds
the number of ways of doing that is
thirteen if I'm buying eleven bagels and
there are two kinds the number of ways
of doing that is twelve and if I'm
buying zero bagels and there are two
kinds the number of ways of doing that
is one and so the total number of ways
of buying these three kinds of bagels
when you're buying a dozen bagels will
be the sum of all the numbers from 13
down to one and that number is the sum
of the first thirteen positive integers
and there's a formula if I have the sum
of the first n positive integers that
formula is given by n times n plus 1
over 2 so in particular here the N is
equal to 13 so the number of ways of
buying bagels when there are three coins
will be 13 times 14 divided by 2 if we
were thinking about a general formula we
might think of that
as 12 plus 1 and the 14 as 12 plus 2 so
it's a number like that it's a fraction
that involves a product of two numbers
and then you divide by two we could do
this forever so for example if there are
four kinds then we might say that we
have maybe onion and the onions would go
from 0 up to 12 and then whenever we
have a number of onions we would
therefore have a number remaining
for the other 3 cons so if we have zero
onions
there will be 12 remaining for the other
three coins and if we go all the way up
to 12 onions that will be 0 remaining
and we saw that if there are 12 bagels
to be purchased the number of ways of
buying 3 kinds is 13 times 14 divided by
2 and if there are 11 bagels there
should be 12 times 13 divided by 2 and
we keep going in this way if we have
zero bagels the number is going to be 1
and at least in this formalism well I
have to take zero and add one to it and
zero and add 2 to it and divide by 2
so that's also going to be 1 so I'll
have a sum of numbers like this you
might think that there would be some way
of evaluating that sum but the answer is
not obvious until you try to do some
kind of analysis of a formula and in
fact what is really needed here is some
other perspective some other way of
doing the problem
let's say we're doing four times so the
first kind that I wrote down was onion
the next kind might be blueberry the
next kind might be bubblegum and the
final kind will be caramel we have our
12 bagels so I'm just writing 12 stars
so far these bagels are unassigned in
terms of their flavor so so far we have
these twelve bagels and I've just
written them with asterisks known in the
trade as stars and I have to decide
which of these stars will be onion which
of the Stars will be blueberry which
will be bubblegum and which will be
caramel and the way I will do that is to
place dividers between the kinds so
let's say that I want to have only one
caramel so I will put a divider
separating off the caramel from the rest
of the bagels and then there's bubblegum
that's a little sketchy maybe I'll take
two Bubblegum's so I'll put a divider
here and then the bubblegum range from
the first divider that I'm writing all
the way to the right to the second
divider let's say I really like
blueberry and I'll take four of them so
I'll write the blueberry bagels here and
that leaves one two three four five
bagels for the onion category so what
have I done
well I've written in a line a certain
number of symbols how many symbols well
there were twelve symbols for the bagels
to start and then in order to separate
out the four cons I needed three
dividers that's a really key point that
the number of dividers is one less than
number of kinds and altogether I've
written 15 symbols and these 15 symbols
twelve are stars and the remaining
symbols are called bars so what I have
are Stars and Bars I have summarized my
choice of kinds of bagels onion
blueberry bubblegum and caramel by
writing down the bars that are
interspersed among the stars and the key
point to this whole analysis is that I
can put the Stars and the bars in any
order I want and for each order that
gives me a choice of how my bag will be
constituted and in order to figure out
where the bars go relative to the Stars
what I have to do is I have to
contemplate some tableau that is
completely blank it's devoid of symbols
we're all together there are going to be
15 symbols and every one of these slots
is capable of housing a star or a bar
and the rule when I make my final
decision is that of these 15 slots 12 of
them have to be stars and three of them
have to be bars so first when you fill
up your styles and bars on this
basically if you have zero of any flavor
it just means you have consecutive bars
in that list that's right except for
example suppose I want no onion right
whatsoever then I would start with a bar
and to the left of the bar
there is no onion there's nothing and
then to the right of the bar there will
be 12 slots for bagels and two more
slots for bars so what we've done is
we've related this bagel problem to
another kind of problem it's a problem
where there are 15 slots total three of
the slots are bars and twelve the slots
are stars and we just have to decide
which are which so this is a standard
combinatorial problem there's a very
simple formula involving factorials so
let's say that I want to analyze this
problem I want to make the choice so
what I'll do is I'll say there are 15
slots to begin with and I have to figure
out where the bars go so let's say I'm
going to place my first bar somewhere
there are 15 possibilities for that
first bar so I write the 15 15 choices
once I have placed down the first bar
there will be 14 remaining choices for
the second bar so I'll multiply by 14
and then there will be 13 choices for
the third bar and I seem to have this
product as the number of ways of making
my choices however that's not completely
correct because when I put down these
bars these bars all have equals
status it's not like there's a first bar
a second bar or a third bar even though
we do have an orientation there's left
to right when I say I'm going to put
down my first bar I could have put down
this bar this bar or this bar and so I
have to divide by a factor that shows
you the number of ways of permuting
around the three bars and the number of
ways of doing that is there are three
bars I get three choices to say which
one was going to be the first and then
two choices remaining to see which will
be the second and then there's only one
choice for the third bar so that's
removed from the order that removes the
problem of ordering and so what we have
here for four kinds is we have to go
back to the previous situation where
we're looking at one kind and two cons
and three cons we have 13 which is 12
plus 1 we have 14 which is 12 plus 2 and
we have 15 which is 12 plus 3 and then
we divide by 1 times 2 times 3 so that's
another way to summarize what we have
here and if you are familiar with
notation of combinations or binomial
coefficients this product divided by the
denominator product is written 15 2 3
and 15 choose 3 has a standard notation
that identifies what it is it's the
product of all the the first 15 positive
integers that's called 15 factorial
divided by the product of the first
three positive integers that's 3
factorial and then divided by the
factorial of 15 minus 3 that'll be 12
factorial and in fact you can see that
this is another way of writing what I've
already written because if I take 15
factorial and divide by 12 factorial I
am taking the product of the first 15
integers and removing the product of the
first 12 integers and what's left are
the integers from 13 to 15 13 times 14
times 15 so 15 factorial divided by 12
factorial
is the same product that we have in the
numerator and the 3 factorial is 3 times
2 times 1 which also appears and what's
interesting about this formula is that
there's a symmetry it's symmetric
between the number of bars and a number
of stars and that makes perfect sense
because when I'm choosing the bagel
coins I can say well I'm going to choose
the places where the bars go down where
the dividers go down but symmetrically I
can choose the places where the bagels
go down leaving 3 remaining slots for
the bars to generalize it if you had had
to buy 20 bagels and there were 6
flavors okay so if there are 20 bagels
that means 20 stars and if there are 6
flavors that means there are 5 bars and
the answer then would be that I take the
total number of slots which will be 20
plus 5 and I choose symmetrically either
the 20 slots that are stars or the 5
slots that are bars yeah this is the
famous Berkley Campanelli yeah so let's
say in general that we have n bagels and
there are K kinds of bagels while K cons
corresponds to K minus 1 bars and so the
total number of symbols is going to be n
which is the number of bagels plus K
minus 1 which is the number of dividers
and the number of ways of choosing the
end bagels when there are K cons is the
number of ways of choosing K minus 1
things from a total of n plus K minus 1
slots and symmetrically that's the same
as choosing n things from a situation
where there are n plus K minus 1 slots
and let me just also write that in terms
of factorials if you like this is n plus
K minus 1 factorial divided by the
product of 2 5
toriel's n factorial and K minus 1
factorial what happens if we have more
flavors than we need bagels like if you
are only buying five bagels and there
are 10 flavors it just means that there
will be quite a few bars that are either
at the end of the configuration the next
two other bars the same problem occurs
in disguise if you ask students the
following sort of question suppose you
have a bag of twelve identical lollipops
and there are four children and you want
to distribute these twelve lollipops to
the forest children how many ways can
you do that the answer is that you
should take these children and you
should give them temporary names you
should call one child onion one child
blueberry the third child will be called
bubblegum and the fourth child will
become caramel and so you have really
exactly the same problem and has exactly
the same answer switch there's only one
thing to switch to in this case it's
door number three are you going to stay
with your choice or are you going to
make that leap to something different
and very often contestants would stand
there agonized right so they've got some
new information this tickles which stick
or switch